on problem 91 91 by what percent did the
median household so median is middle by
what percent did the median household
income in country Y decrease from 1970
to 1980 so they want a percentage in
1970 to 1980 median household income
alright statement number one tells us in
1970 the median household income in
country Y was two-thirds of the median
household income in country X so let's
write Y in 1970 let's just write 70
because the 19 is redundant
the median income in country Y in 1970
is equal to two-thirds of the median
income if country X in 1970
that's what statement l1 tells us but
one again that doesn't I mean we don't
know about what happened in 1980 in
country Y so we still can't answer the
question statement number two in 1980
the median the median household income
in country Y so Y in 1980 was one-half
the median household income in country X
in 1980 now you might be tempted to say
oh to linear equations and two unknowns
maybe I can solve for it
etc but no there's actually two linear
equations in four unknowns right this is
y in 1970 is different than Y in 1980
and X in 1970 is different than X in
1980 so there's actually four variables
but you say oh no no but we don't need
to figure out all the variables we just
need to figure out the percent decline
right they just say by what percent did
the median household income in country Y
decrease from 1970 to 1980 so
essentially if we could figure out this
if we could figure out if we could
figure out why 80 over y 71
what the percent decline was right if
this number is 0.8 then it would be a
40% decline if this number was 0.5 then
would be a 50% decline so whatever this
number is that that's essentially 1 -
that is a percentage - maybe we just
have to figure out this but look I can
prove you mathematically that we still
can't figured out this because why 80
divided by why 70 that's equal to
two-thirds X on the side why 80 so why
80 that's 1/2 X in 1980 divided by 2/3 X
in 1970 right and then let's see if we
could multiply take this three halves up
we get let's see 1 divided by 1/3 3
becomes 3 over 2 so it becomes 3/4 X 80
over X 70 so this we're still you know
they never told us what the median with
a median household income in country X
was in any year so we still can't solve
this problem so there's not enough
information given
next problem 92 a certain group of car
dealerships agreed to donate X dollars
to a Red Cross chapter for each car sold
during a 30 day period what was the
total amount that was expected to be
donated that was expected to be donated
so the total amount let's say donation
is going to be equal to is going to be
equal to X dollars times the number of
cars times cars and this is what we need
to figure out we need to figure out what
the donations are equal to or the
expected donations it says a total of
500 cars were expected to be sold so it
is essentially telling us that C is
equal to 500 we still can't figure out
what D is because we don't know how many
dollars are are we getting for each car
so that is not enough information by
itself statement 260 more cars were sold
than expected so the total amount
actually donated was $28,000 interesting
so so essentially it's saying that C
Plus so if you had an extra 60 cars than
expected right 500 were expected to be
sold actually we could just say 500 were
expected to be sold 660 more cars were
sold than expected so 60 more were sold
than expected so this is the actual
number that were sold and then that
times the amount donated per car is
equal to $28,000 well now we do have
enough information to figure out well
let's think about it we have enough
information from this to figure out X
right we could say well actually let's
let's let me well we definitely have
enough information now to figure out X
if we use statement number one I just
want to be careful to make sure that we
can't solve this just with statement
number two so we definitely you know if
I just said 560 X is equal to $28,000
then you get X is equal to X is equal to
28,000 over 560 so then the amount that
was expected to be donated would be
28,000 over 560 that's what X is
whatever that number is times the amount
that was the number of cars that were
expected to be sold times 500 and
actually yeah you you have to have
statement 1 there because statement 2 60
more cars were sold actually let me
think about that
so both combined when I use both of the
information it definitely works let me
see if I can figure it out just using
statement 2 alone I don't think I can
but I'm I have a nagging feeling that
there may be giving more information
than I'm so let me say that the car is
expected to C so C so this is what
statement 2 actually is telling us I
assumed the 500 which I shouldn't have
done so statement 2 is actually telling
when I have 60 more than the car is
expected to be sold times X I raised
$28,000 right this alone is not on you
you don't know what X or C is because at
the end of the day at the end of the day
you need to know what x times C is x
times C is our goal so if you distribute
it this out you get X
C+ 60 X is equal to $28,000 and you get
X C is equal to 28,000 minus 60 X so
this is as much information you can
glean just from statement number two so
that alone is not enough I mean if you
could figure out what X is you're done
you actually don't need to know the
expected number of cars sold you just
would know well actually that's true a
statement one so you need both of these
statements to solve the problem anyway
as you can see I haven't done these
problems before so sometimes I'm not
sure and and sometimes I might even get
him wrong problem 93 problem 93 while
driving on the expressway did Robin ever
exceed the 55 mile an hour speed limit
well who knows statement 1 Robin drove a
hundred miles she drove 100 miles well
that doesn't tell me whether she ever
went more than I'm assuming it's a she I
guess it's an androgynous sounding name
that still doesn't tell me whether she
went over a hundred miles to Robin drove
for two hours on the expressway so time
is equal to two hours so each of these
independently give me no information
about how fast she went but I can if I
use both of them I can figure out her
average speed I can say well she went a
hundred miles in two hours average speed
is equal to 50 miles per hour now the
question is did Robin ever exceed the
speed limit well I don't know it's
completely possible that she just went
up to 50 50 miles an hour well in order
to in order to you know we don't know
how fast her car accelerates she might
just gone you know she accelerated
really fast got to 55 stayed there or
went down a little bit and ended up
averaging at 55 she never exceeded it
but she could have easily gone 80 miles
an hour at some point and then slowed
down and taken a break and had a picnic
we don't know so this and this by itself
is not enough information to figure out
if she ever exceeded the speed limit if
her average speed was 56 miles per hour
then we know that she had to exceed the
speed limit
because well at you know at we can
assume that at some point while she was
going at least 56 miles per hour and
especially if we can assume that she
started at a standstill because then
you'd have to go even faster than the
average to make up for the time that
you're going slower but anyway there's
not enough information here to figure it
out just knowing that her average speed
was 50 next problem 94 in Jefferson
school 300 students study French or
Spanish or both if a hundred okay this
sounds like a diet Venn diagram French
or Spanish or both so this is French
this is Spanish so this is French this
is Spanish and this right here is both
in the intersection if a hundred of
these students do not study French okay
they study French or Spanish or both
there's not an option to do neither
if a hundred of these students do not
study French how many of these students
studied both French and Spanish so
Spanish so when they tell us that 100 of
these students do not study French that
tells us that this area let me color it
in a suitably suitably garish color that
tells us that oh no that's not what I
want to do let me that tells us that
this area right here is a hundred so
essentially the people who are studying
Spanish but but not French is a hundred
right and they're asking how many of
these students study both French and
Spanish so they essentially want to know
the intersection of French and Spanish
that purple area is what the question
asks so let's explore the statements
statement number one tells us of the 300
students 60 do not study Spanish 60 no
Spanish so that's essentially telling us
this area this area not not this just
this so that tells us how many study
French only that's 60 I still doesn't
help us to know the intersection
statement number two says a total of two
40 of the students study Spanish 240
study Spanish well I think this alone is
enough information right because they're
telling us that this purple area plus
this yellow area is equal to 240 we want
to figure out the purple area right so
purple plus of the total number of
people who study Spanish it's the people
who study French and Spanish which is
this purple area plus the people who
only study Spanish which they gave us in
the problem was a hundred and then
statement number two says that that is
equal to 240 so the people who study
French and Spanish has to be the purple
area which is 240 minus 100 which is 140
which we don't have to figure out the
number we just have to know that 2 gives
us enough information by itself to solve
the problem and we don't even need
problem number we don't even need
statement number one and I'm out of time
see you the next video